LUKE KENNARD.
MORRIS EXTRA PASS.
REGGIE JACKSON A THREE.
SIDE OF THE BACKBOARD.
AND CRAIG GETS THE REBOUND.
>> Jeff: THAT WAS A MUCH BETTER
CLOSE BY AYTON.
>> Mike: BOOK SEES SOME ROOM.
BASELINE JUMPER ROLLS OFF THE
RIM.
BALL STILL ALIVE.
KNOCKED LOOSE.
PICKED UP BY KENNARD.
LOST IT THERE.
A FOUL FROM BEHIND.
BEVERLEY KNOCKS DOWN DeANDRE
AYTON.
>> Jeff: THAT IS A FLAGRANT.
>> Mark: I DON'T THINK SO.
A BIG GUY UNDER THE RIM GOING TO
DRUNK IT.
>> Jeff: YOU KNOW HOW SCREWED UP
THE RULE IS.
WE NEVER CAN AGREE.
I SAY YES, YOU SAY NO.
THIS LOOKED OBVIOUS TO ME.
WIND UP.
IMPACT.
FOLLOW THROUGH.
>> Mark: THAT IS NOT A FLAGRANT
FOUL TO ME.
WINDUP TO HIT THE DUNK.
>> Mike: I THINK THAT IS A
FLAGRANT ONE, MARK.
HIT HIM ON THE HEAD.
>> Mark: I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Jeff: HE GOT THE BALL FIRST
I'LL SAY THAT FOR YOUR CASE.
>> Mark: YOU KNOW WHAT IS MESSED
UP UP?
IF YOU'RE OVER THERE COACHING
YOU WOULD SAY GREAT BASKETBALL.
>> Jeff: I AGREE WITH YOU.
BUT YOU'RE SO STRANGE ON ALL OF
THIS.
A GUY GETS LOVE TAPPED INTO THE
FACE ON A JUMP SHOT AND YOU
THINK A CRIME HAS BEEN COMMITTED
AND NOW DOWN AT THIS END, A GUY
TAKES A WINDUP AND SLAMS THE GUY
PROBABLY, HAS A CONCUSSION NOW
AND YOU'RE GOOD WITH THAT?
LIKE YOU MAKE NO SENSE!
>> Mark: NO.
YOU SHOULD BE THE LAST PERSON ON
EARTH TO CALL ME STRENGTH.
>> Jeff: NO.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
>> Mike: LET'S CHECK IN WITH
STEVE JAVIE ONCE AGAIN.
>> Jeff: SIDE WITH ME ONCE IN
YOUR LIFE!
>> Steve: I LOVE YOU GUYS GOING
BACK AND FORTH.
THIS IS WONDERFUL.
I BELIEVE NOW IN MY OPINION, ANY
WAY, YOU HAVE THE WINDUP.
THE IMPACT HE DOES HAVE THE BALL
BUT HE HITS HIM UNDER THE HEAD
THERE.
SEVERITY OF CONTACT AND WHERE
THE CONTACT OCCURS.
I THINK, IN MY OPINION, THIS
WOULD BE A FLAGRANT ONE BECAUSE
OF THE WINDUP AND THEN HIM
HITTING HIM IN THE HEAD.
>> Mike: IT'S GOING TO BE
BEVERLEY'S SECOND FOUL, WHETHER
IT'S A COMMON FOUL OR THE
FLAGRANT.
>> Mark: THE WINDUP HITS THE
BASKETBALL FIRST.
HE IS WINDING UP TO BLOCK A BIG
GUY'S DUNK.
>> Jeff: YOU'RE REELING ME BACK
INTO YOUR SIDE.
>> Mike: AYTON IS OFF TO A GOOD
START HERE IN THE FIRST HALF.
TEN POINTS, FIVE REBOUNDS.
MARC DAVIS, THE CREW CHIEF,
TAKING A LONG LOOK AT IT.
>> Jeff: IT'S GOING TO BE CALLED
A FLAGRANT FOUL.
WHETHER WE AGREE WITH IT OR NOT
IS JUST HOW IT IS.
>> Referee: REPLAY HAS
DETERMINED THIS FOUL TO BE A
COMMON FOUL.
WE HAVE TWO FREE THROWS.
>> Jeff: YOU ARE ON A ROLL!
>> Mark: STEVE JAVIE, YOU NEED
TO FLY ME TO CHICAGO, MAN.
>> Mike: ALL BALL.
>> Mark: IT'S NOT ALL BALL.
IT'S A FOUL BUT HE DID BLOCK IT.
>> Mike: BEVERLEY IS SGLANG IT
TO DEVIN BOOKER WHO HAS ZERO
INTEREST IN LISTENING TO HIM
RIGHT NOW.
>> Jeff: THE REFEREES DECIDE
THAT, RIGHT?
>> Mike: YES.
>> Jeff: BUT MOST OF THE REPLAY
IS DECIDED BACK IN SECAUCUS AND
THE REFEREES ARE THERE JUST TO
SORT OF --
>> Mike: BOOKER WANTS TO TALK TO
JOHN GOBLE.
>> Jeff: I LIKE BOOKER'S